this is Alfred Hitchcock having lived
with psycho since it was a gleam in my
camera's eye I now exercise my parental
rights in revealing a number of
significant facts about this slightly
extraordinary entertainment this is a
press book on film an advanced press
book to present to you a visual story on
the care and handling of Alfred
Hitchcock's Psycho the scene is the
DeMille Theatre in New York the entire
motion picture industry knows that
psycho is being exhibited with a special
presentation policy a creation of
Paramount Pictures showmanship the man
in the tuxedo is Nick Justin of the
DeMille theater he is a theater manager
he is the main instrument of the policy
listen now to the heart of the policy
I've suggested a psycho be seen from the
beginning in fact this is more than a
suggestion it is required and here is
what Broadway saw no one but no one will
be admitted to the theater after the
start of each performance of psycho the
audience had been sold this concept with
it they were sold on cycle mr. Hitchcock
tells you as he told them why this of
course is to help you enjoy psycho more
we really have only your enjoyment in
mind the campaign began with newspaper
teaser ads calling attention to
explaining selling the policy the keep
the story a secret idea supplemented the
policy special Hitchcock ads well in
advance announced why it was desirable
to see psycho from the beginning
close to opening day another Hitchcock
ad told why it was required and clearly
supplied the audience with the time
schedule of psycho performances as did
every display ad before psycho open the
directory ads after opening confirmed
the psycho policy gave the show times
clearly when they came to the theater
the audience saw Hitchcock in person
well not really but with him there was a
real live Pinkerton policeman to
emphasize the policy story which the
newspaper ads had pre-sold we won't
allow you to cheat yourself you must see
psycho from the beginning to end to
enjoy it fully therefore do not expect
to be admitted into the theater after
the start of each performance of the
picture we say no one and we mean no one
not even the managers brother the
President of the United States or the
Queen of England god bless her
everywhere in print and sound the policy
was emphatically and entertainingly told
I insist that you do not tell your
friends the little tiny horrifying
secrets of psycho after you see it I
would also like to point out the psycho
is most enjoyable when viewed beginning
at the beginning and proceeding to the
end the newspaper campaign the publicity
the big sell on the entire special
presentation policy brought the audience
to the theater well in advance of
performance times paramount with the
assistance of mr. Hitchcock was prepared
to sell them again inform them and
entertain them with a set of specially
recorded la me spots I must apologize
for inconveniencing you in this way
however this curing up and standing
about is good for you it will make you
appreciate the seats inside it will also
make you appreciate psycho
see cycler is handling of the lines of
people who had come to see psycho and
every showman knows that these were its
best advertisement was the one main
challenge of the psycho policy the box
office was always clear for ticket
selling by the device of a ticket
holders line the advertised times were
for the start of each complete
performance which began exactly at the
end title of the previous showing of
psycho for the large capacity DeMille
theater there was a 25 minute break
allowing time for the spill and the fill
of the theater this break included a
program of shorts and newsreel just
prior to the next showing of psycho at
peak audience showings the program of
shorts could be reduced to meet the need
ticket sales were momentarily stopped at
the moment the feature ended psycho
ticket holders who had been waiting were
admitted first the ticket sales were
resumed of course during the balance of
the break time a special Hitchcock 40 by
60 Stan B which is being supplied to
every engagement of psycho carried the
exact starting time of the feature
itself at the moment the opening titles
of psycho hit The Scream the new time
for the next showing of the feature was
announced at the theater front there was
an occasional late arrival the cashier
at all the theater staff of course were
ready to explain the presentation policy
and politely offered that a ticket could
be purchased now for the next
performance of psycho in New York and in
Chicago and in Boston and in
Philadelphia for pre-release engagements
the policy of a special presentation of
psycho has proved itself it has proved
itself in the best way it can smash box
office business highly entertained
patrons moviegoers now in the hundreds
of thousands who enjoyed psycho because
they saw it under the one set of
circumstances that would ensure their
enjoyment the presentation policy for
psycho has made it a most special
attract
leading to big business big
word-of-mouth and building to even
bigger business for you every paramount
exchange and the Paramount Home Office
is ready now to consult with you and
make you a partner in this extraordinary
showmanship plan and to furnish you with
a detailed start to finish manual on the
care and handling of psycho paramount
has brought Alfred Hitchcock's exciting
new entertainment to its fullest
potential by making a point of powerful
points to the motion picture audience
the point of all this of course is to
help you enjoy psycho more you see I
like you I want you to be happy what
more can I say my name is George Weltner
and I am vice president of Paramount
Pictures in charge of world sales what
you have just seen in this film is a
demonstration of revolutionary
showmanship it has brought to us at
Paramount what I can only describe as a
smash hit Alfred Hitchcock's production
of psycho as of this moment has played
in every kind of situation in four of
the major key cities New York
Philadelphia Boston and Chicago as well
as in such surroundings smaller
situations as Morristown New Jersey and
Stanford Connecticut and in driving
engagements such as New Brunswick New
Jersey it has been established as one of
the biggest grocers in the history of
Paramount we were convinced that the
theater policy for psycho was right when
we launched it in our first four key
city dates naturally with the results
now before us all we are more convinced
than ever as far as we are concerned we
intend to maintain the special handling
policy on psycho through each and every
engagement of its play off as you will
find from your paramount exchange we
have assembled the whole rain
of our experience with a picture and we
are making it available to you in every
possible way right now I would like to
go even one step further there is no
doubt the personal efforts of exhibitors
where they have made themselves part of
the policy where they have brought their
intelligence and experience into the
handling of the picture have been a most
important factor in the success of
psycho I have with me in the studio
today a perfect cross-section of the
management of theatres of every type I
can think of nothing more significant
and important than to have you hear from
them directly
this is mr. Mel Miller managing director
of the Palace Theatre in Stamford
Connecticut the Palace Theatre is
located in suburban town we follow the
campaign and the policy set forth by
Paramount for the showing of psycho
the results were wonderful we did more
business with psycho than any other
picture has done in our town in the past
30 years I heartily recommend to every
exhibitor that he follow the policy of
psycho if he wishes to do as well as we
did this is mr. Barney Cohen manager of
the Arcadia theater in Philadelphia I
was very happy with Paramount's idea of
Lowry no one into the theater once the
picture had started being in the lobby
and being in the streets for the people
and with the tours paramount gave me to
work with
I feel psycho will be a huge success
here is Joe Appleman owner of the New
Brunswick drive-in theater we operate
the Brunswick drive-in theater in New
Brunswick New Jersey we were not certain
whether Paramount's policy have no
admission after the picture had begun
would be good for us at the drive-in
theater but after operating with that
policy I can conclusively say that not
only did it help us in the first time we
showed the ship feature but it also
helped us the second time we showed the
feature at twelve o'clock at night and
we had cars backed up on the highway for
three to five miles on the particular
nights that we showed this picture and
here
mr. Walter Reed jr. of the DeMille and
baronet theaters in New York City of
course being concerned with the first
engagement of psycho anyways we had the
same reaction the same reservation the
same feeling that any of you might have
all I can say is that the results are
fantastic it's plausible practical the
public love the policy and there's no
reason that I can possibly think of why
it won't work any place in the United
States